from a beef between show hosts to a beef
between co-hosts Ridiculousness may have
been known for its Wild video clips but
it was nothing compared to what happened
behind the scenes
at the beginning of every episode a
warning tells viewers not to attempt any
stunts or activities presented
throughout the show it also condemns the
submission of videos of any kind from
viewers if Ridiculousness doesn't accept
submissions then where are they getting
their Clips since the viral videos come
from the internet it sounds as simple as
a Google search but licensing is a
tricky business in a 2019 interview with
John interviews host Rob Dyrdek revealed
he isn't the one searching for the
videos but instead has a massive
organization that handles the process a
team of people scours the internet and
when the perfect video is found they try
to make contact with the video's
original uploader distractify notes that
someone on Reddit claimed to receive a
one-time 200 payment for their video
it's unclear if this is a regular
practice for the show but with an
endless supply of videos online we don't
have to worry about Rob running out of
hilarious content
talk about a major ear worm if you're
not old enough to know of the hit 80s
rock band Devo you might think the
catchy theme song came from
Ridiculousness however the theme song is
actually a cover of Devo's
uncontrollable urge from the band's
classic debut album Q are we not men a
we Are Devo in season 4 episode 9 of
Fantasy Factory Deer dick teams up with
Devo band member Mark mothersbaugh to
record the cover for Ridiculousness
mother's ball has an expansive career
himself along with co-founding the band
Devo his solo Endeavors have included
composing music for film and TV such as
Nickelodeon's Rugrats and Wes Anderson's
features bottle rocket Rushmore the
Royal Tenenbaums and The Life Aquatic
with Steve zisu so next time the
Ridiculousness theme song gets stuck in
your head you know who to blame
Ridiculousness isn't only big in the U.S
the show airs all around the globe but
instead of dubbing episodes each country
gets its own hosts reacting to Clips in
2015 ridiculous Chile was the first
international version of the show
followed by ridiculous made in France
verguenza Hena made in Spain and more in
2016. the effective format of
ridiculousness has also been used in
multiple spin-offs including MTV's
amazingness deliciousness messiness and
adorableness the first spin-off
amazingness deviated the most from the
Ridiculousness format hosted by Dyrdek
himself the talent competition ran from
December 2017 to January 2018 featuring
six contestants performing in front of
judges Chris Drama faff Eddie Huang and
Crystal b a ten thousand dollar prize
was awarded to the final performer
standing the other three spin-offs do
not feature deer deck but they stay true
to his style Tiffany Thiessen
commentates on disastrous food related
Clips on deliciousness James Davis
commentates on the kind of clips that
make you cry out awe on adorableness and
Snooki commentates on pure Chaos on
messiness
MTV's launch in 1981 changed the course
of Television by being the first to air
24 7 music related programming and music
videos however with the internet
offering a new way for fans to access
music content the network pivoted to the
reality programming genre this jarring
change in content devastated an entire
generation but on August 1st 2021 MTV's
40th anniversary the network had the
perfect opportunity to cater to longtime
viewers when scheduling was announced
Gen X was disappointed all over again
instead of the usual 113 hours a week of
ridiculousness MTV celebrated its
birthday by playing the show for 24
hours straight Twitter users and Outlets
such as bar stool Sports expressed their
outrage while Ridiculousness fans
celebrated in the background
a hot topic of discussion around
Ridiculousness is the longtime feud
between dear deck and Daniel Tosh of
Tosh.0 it all started with a tweet from
Tosh congrats Rob Dyrdek new show looks
very funny and familiar dear deck
tweeted back thank you so much Daniel
Tosh maybe later this week you Bob Saget
and Tom Bergeron can come down to my
factory and play in an interview with
Larry King deer deck revealed that both
Ridiculousness and Fantasy Factory were
pitched and sold before Tosh.0 aired but
Fantasy Factory was produced first
by the time my Ridiculousness came out
it was already after the first season of
Tosh came out right it can be argued
there are more differences between the
shows than similarities the comedy
styles are on opposite sides of the
spectrum with Tosh.0 taking a more
scripted approach and sprinkling skits
into episodes the argument between the
two came to a head when Tosh featured a
sketch targeting deer deck for copying
his Show's premise in a now deleted
tweet deerdeck responded with I am not a
comedian or an actor so unfortunately
for Daniel Tosh we are going to have to
settle this the old-fashioned way this
was followed by Tasha's tweet fair
enough but if you have to beat me up can
we film it and put it on my show so
people will actually watch it
deirdex co-hosts Chanel West Coast and
Stilo brim play a significant role in
the show's success brim controls the
playback of the clips slowing down
rewinding and zooming in on the funniest
moments and it isn't an episode of
Ridiculousness without Chanel's
contagious laugh so how did deer deck
find his two co-hosts Chicago native
Steelo Brim moved to Los Angeles to
pursue a music career brim told CBS news
that he was helping deirdek's cousin
start a publishing and production
company when he met Rob Rob you still
having to come to the studio like twice
and she's like hey man you're funny you
should do a show together
deer deck followed through by bringing
on brim as co-host of ridiculousness he
also regularly appeared in Fantasy
Factory and dear deck's animation series
Wild Grinders as the voice of meaty in
an interview on the podcast no jumper
Chanel explained how she managed to meet
deer deck through Myspace I would go and
I would add all the top artists on
MySpace and then I'd add all their top
friends one of those artists was dear
deck's cousin Chris dramafaff through a
friendship with him Chanel met dear deck
and hit it off the rest as they say is
history
yet another Feud Sparks between Chanel
West Coast and radio hosts Charlemagne
the God in episode 26 of season 9
Charlemagne appears as a guest host on
the show during the episode Charlemagne
says he values being straightforward
with people and not being afraid to
convey his opinions to people's faces
one of those opinions is about Chanel's
rapping abilities
I told her she was whack rapping one
time Chanel defended herself against the
claims
saying though you can have opinions it
doesn't mean they're right though she
then flaunts her long list of
accomplishments as an established artist
Outlets blew the story up but Chanel
admits the beef didn't last more than
five minutes she tells too Fab it's not
so much that I took it personally it's
that I knew he was stating I was a whack
rapper on a platform where all my fans
were watching the last thing I was gonna
do was let somebody call me a whack
rapper and not use that time right there
to State the facts and set things
straight
can you think of a better job than
getting to react to funny videos all day
long with your friends still that
doesn't take away from how much hard
work it takes to film hundreds of
episodes over the course of 28 Seasons
what started as filming a single episode
for 12 hours turned into filming six
episodes daily brim attributes this
change to the hosts taking on a more
improvisational style each episode calls
for an outfit change and the host's
energy varies depending on how early or
late the production is into filming
Chanel told in touch that there's a
reason why she sometimes looks tired if
you ever see me looking a little extra
tired it's probably either the last
episode of the day or it's the first
episode of the day where I was still
really tired
deer deck never wanted to be the old guy
on TV his one true passion has always
been entrepreneurship but it was
impossible to pass up the money that
came with his shows on MTV in an
interview with graham bensinger Dyrdek
talked about how he almost walked away
from Ridiculousness I don't want to be
on MTV when I'm when I'm 40. I don't
want to be Kurt loader it's no secret
that money has played a significant role
in Deer deck's longtime partnership with
MTV so how much does he make from
Ridiculousness in an interview on Jason
tartik's podcast trading Secrets deer
deck revealed the number they would only
pay me thirty five thousand dollars an
episode to do Ridiculousness and then
they offered me the 125 000 and then
when I got the integration rights then
I'm like I'm just gonna do this because
I can just make millions doing this
later on three shows in with MTV Dyrdek
said I was able to get way more money
based on the success of what had
happened with Fantasy Factory of course
that 125 thousand dollars is just the
talent fee that number doesn't even
include the money made from integration
deals that deerduck took advantage of in
all his shows deirdek explained that if
MTV didn't offer a massive paycheck
season 4 would have ended his hosting
gig for Ridiculousness MTV knew the
stakes were high so when it came to
negotiations deirdek had a leg up and
got an offer he couldn't refuse after
the signing of the contract deirdek
called MTV a great partner as an
entrepreneur Dyrdek didn't just get
lucky he knew exactly what he was doing
and used his platform on MTV as a way to
make millions elsewhere the entire
premise of fantasy factory was tailored
around product integration deer deck
would write intricate integrated brand
Partnerships with advertisers into the
show and then would use those same
advertisers to make other big deals on
the side for his own Ventures whether
he's promoting clothing brands by
wearing them on Robin big and
Ridiculousness or doing stunts in a
Carl's Jr costume on Fantasy Factory
Deer deck's Savvy marketing skills
granted him ability to broaden his
financial reach beyond the MTV Network
in addition to a fun laugh filled Time
Each episode of Ridiculousness offers a
variety of star-studded guest hosts some
of the most popular appearances include
from riffraff and Ray J from season 3
Kendall and Kylie Jenner from season 5
Eric Andre from season 6 8 and 20 and
dear deck's frequent collaborator
Christopher Big Black Boykin who
tragically passed in 2017. more recent
episodes have seen a decline in
Celebrity guest hosts but some of the
show's most memorable moments can be
linked to their many guests take for
example an episode with Kevin Hart where
an entire segment titled big ass man
pigeons was inspired by Hart's fearful
encounter with an ostrich he didn't move
his body but his head like spent all the
way around and he started following me
and I was like yo man get the [ __ ] out
of here
only Ridiculousness can think of a
connection like that or Eric Andre's
visits which largely consists of him
flirting with co-host Chanel West Coast
and an email's worth of swear words that
needed to be censored after taping one
way or another celebrities are always
bringing something special to
ridiculousness
most people aren't familiar with Chanel
West Coast's long-term connection to the
Ridiculousness Studio Chanel has taken
many different Avenues in her career
from recording music to acting in MTV's
the hard times of RJ Berger to becoming
a supporting cast member on the reality
TV series Love and Hip Hop Hollywood
however as Chanel told in touch a
recurring theme in her career has always
been the Hollywood center Studio where
Ridiculousness does its filming and
there's some there's like this weird
Divine thing about this studio like my
first job was there and then I ended up
filming Ridiculousness there maybe we
can attribute the great success of
ridiculousness to this magical
occurrence one can only hope Chanel's
future endeavors will have her revisit
the studio time and time again
thank you